you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is the game
between Judit Polgar playing on the
white end and Ference burkas this is
from 2003
Judit was rated 2715 and Ference was
rated 2578 i think you'll enjoy this 24
mover it contains a couple i catching
moves to say the least and one of them
you may just end up falling in love with
it's really a remarkable move a
beautiful idea so Judith the strongest
female chess player of all time and a
former world number 8 kicking off with a
form
ference a former world under 18 champion
and player who would become Hungarian
chess champion not once not twice but
six times playing the French defense in
this one let's see what variation burn
variation capturing on e4 move four and
one imbalance on board Bishop for Knight
exchange black has an option to inject
yet another inbounds but prefers to keep
the structure intact Knight f3 castles
where are we going it's another case
another game of opposite sides castling
black takes some time out to preserve
the bishop pair another idea is to
simply get on with completing
development Bishop d3 b6 only no and the
first punch is thrown what to do h6
now couple ideas white could run with
here one of them is to play h4 and you
know basically provide a hook to that
night and say you take my night I will
soon be taking your king that open H
file will be too much for black to deal
with Judah has a different idea let's
see what her idea is in the game check
on h7 King to h8 and now
Bishop to e4 so by inserting the check
first white is saying I prefer to have
your King in the corner I feel that the
king is more vulnerable in the corner
then he is on the g8 square and on the
surface it appears that White is saying
if you take my knight I take your ruck
well that's what black does black takes
the knight
but Judit now does not take the rook and
instead makes the move gee farm
I'm still here I just want to give a
little pause there to allow you to wrap
your head around what just happened
right there
Black's last move took one of your minor
pieces white is in a position now where
you can follow up and take a major piece
and you don't and instead you make a
pawn move and of all moves g4 with these
four weaknesses what in the world is
going on here well let me explain
first why the rook is poison if Judah
captures the rook this is what black has
in mind
G for scaring the night away he
shouldn't move but if he does now the
Queen would be cooked so the end result
will basically be if you capture the
rook black will end up getting two minor
pieces the Knights been going to be
captured in black will be the side for
choice so didn't move g4 prevents this
idea of chasing the night away and
following up with Bishop to g5 and now a
genuinely threatens to win the rook in
the corner and one more thing and the
most important thing and I don't know
the coolest thing with this move
it's simply fixing the pawn on g5 why is
this important well guess what the
follow-up is why was that check inserted
why is the King more vulnerable on h8
well what's right around the right
around the corners h4 this h-file will
be ripped open black cannot stop white
from having an h-file peeled open so
what is black to rook to b8 in comes H
form
the h-file will open up the rooks will
play this cannot be stopped that's what
you get with that g4 move how awesome is
that I love that move if you take here
the black plays the move g6 but if you
capture white would play g5 there's now
a disconnect the bishop can't see h4 and
white will be winning this position very
soon capturing doubling maybe even
tripling it's too much
what is black try g6 H takes G check
g7 in comes the Queen this is a super
active post for her what does black do
here Bishop to b7 I'd like to cover a
what-if at this point it's important
suppose
black immediately challenges this rook
what would the follow-up be here this is
what white would do capture the rook
after Queen takes is otherwise King
takes there's Queen takes f7 so after
this recapture what white would do is
play Knight to e5 and there's all sorts
of stuff going in with this first off a
mate and one threat Queen takes f7 in
another is rook to h1 the bishop is now
controlling that square so what to do
from this point well just covering one
option if let's say Knight takes Knight
there would be Queen takes Knight check
King here that's going to be painful and
King here this Queen is way out of
control super active what is what is the
queen not hitting from this position if
there's a check we simply duck where's
the rook going nowhere he's soon to be
watching things from the sidelines so
it's very serious rook here we chop we
jump into e5 it's serious serious
trouble for team black so what is tried
is Bishop to b7 and now the second eye
catching move rook to h7 this is the
only winning continuation Judit now
follows up with the rook sacrifice
luring the King out to this h-file yet
again it's already happened once right
bishop h7 to pull the king here and now
the rook is doing this the Kings getting
pulled over to the h-file yet again he
does not like being on the h-file the
follow-up is now Queen to H to move
order especially important the idea is
to double up on the H file but you can't
just throw the rook here with check you
end up losing
if you go with rook check King here and
then put the Queen here black is in time
to defend it's a very important you play
the game move Queen h2 check because now
if King to g7 the Queen would first play
into h6 and only then would white double
all right Queen h6 the King goes here
and there will be no rip to H a as a
defense
so after this game move queen h2 black
just goes back to g8
why only at this point doubles and what
is tried is Bishop takes pawn check
knight takes Bishop Queen takes Knight
and f4 there's just too much for black
to deal with Queen is it and there are
multiple matin one threats
so black sees it best to simply give up
the Queen there really is not anything
better Bishop takes Bishop Queen takes
Bishop and black throws in the towel it
may seem like well can't black struggle
on some no there's no struggling on in
this position this attack is continuing
and if it isn't at the very least I can
assure you that the White Queen will
officially turn into pac-man hitting the
night hitting the pawn black will lose
all Queen sight pawns and you wouldn't
believe how fast that a pawn can run the
big thing here is that black does not
have coordination and black does not
have any counter play whatsoever so it
is at that point this point right here
after Queen captures Bishop bunny for
that black finally said you know what
I've had enough and yeah what a
beautiful combination this was two times
pulling the King to the H file and that
g4 move is really a one-of-a-kind move I
I can't compare that move to any other
one that I've seen in my chess playing
days so anyhow feel free to leave any
feedback to this game in the comment
section below
hope you're having a great day and I
will catch you in the next video that's
all for now take care bye
you